all right here with reaction Senate
Judiciary Committee chairman Lindsey
Graham said are good to see him shine
merry Christmas to you and your family
very much I read something it's now kind
of infamous on this show called the
Grassley grande memo I don't know if
you're familiar with it
but if any part of the Steele dossier
was used steel himself when push came to
show that I don't know if any of its
true there were multiple warnings given
to the FBI DOJ Bruce or Kathleen
Catholic you can't trust Steel II as an
agenda
Hillary paid for it and it's unverified
right if any of that dossier was used
wouldn't that be a premeditated fraud on
the court but I'm just a simple
talk-show host Monday night maybe I'll
be in your show you will be and play
that clip Monday night play that clip
and let's compare that clip
- what Horowitz has found about the FISA
warrant process and the day of reckoning
is here I don't I haven't been briefed
about the details but I believe it shows
the system completely off the rails for
a long period of time and that you
really have to hate Trump not to be
upset by what the Department of Justice
and the FBI did and there's some things
that they did I believe there are
dangers to democracy let me ask you if I
had a subpoena for my emails and I
decide I'm gonna delete 33 thousand then
I'm gonna have somebody I'm gonna use
something called bleach pit nobody had
ever heard of it alright that'll wipe
the server clean do you think I would be
probably likely brought up on charges of
obstruction you might not be on the
Howard Stern Show he does a penitent
you've sold your soul senator oh yeah
you know really so the bottom line here
is I think the FISA warrant process I'm
looking to the court accountability
meeting the FISA Court yeah so I can
tell you right now that if is as bad as
I think it is I expect the court to make
sure it never happens again
if the counterintelligence investigation
was a sham that I think it is we need to
make sure that never happens again by
creating rules I want to know did Obama
know did Obama know that president
candidate Trump's campaign was being
surveilled by our government and here's
the question I'm dying to know if you
really believe Carter page and
Papadopoulos were working for the
Russians
why didn't you tell President Trump so
he could do something about it like you
told Dianne Feinstein you can't have a
counterintelligence investigation
without the Oval Office Andy McCarthy is
that true I don't believe you could have
one on the Republican candidate for
president without it going up that high
just think of what happened in 2016 the
Republican nominee for president the
United States people that were
associated with his campaign were
surveilled by the government the goal of
a counterintelligence investigation is
to protect people to let Dianne
Feinstein know their this guy that we
think may be working with the Chinese
need to do something about it they told
Hillary about efforts to compromise her
campaign they followed these guys in
different ways for months multiple
warrants were reissued based on the
dossier paid for by the Democratic Party
that footnote in the in the dossier
there there's a footnote that I'm going
to talk to you about in the FISA
application a lot at the top of a FISA
warrant application doesn't it say
verified right okay so if it's
unverifiable and you use the information
that's a problem all right walk us
through Michael Horowitz report on
Monday right he's before your committee
on Wednesday now is he gonna have a
chance to really lay out the case what
would that much time will you give him
all the time he needs so here's the deal
the report comes out Monday but you
really won't understand it until he
testifies Wednesday he's got to put it
in context he's got to tell you what is
in there and how one thing connects to
the other he'll have all the time he
needs I'll have time to ask him
questions I'm gonna basically go through
the FISA warrant process what he found
and ask him
is this defrauding the court was there
was the court mistreated but the
counterintelligence investigation very
low standard to open one are you okay
with this should every politician in
America be worried and I think the
answer is going to be yes because if
they can surveil our campaigns and never
tell us about what they're doing then
that really truly is fine so a big week
next week I think we I've been waiting
say
oh don't even get me started I'm not I'm
not the most patient host senator we're
good to see thank you for stopping good
to see you